>> Hi my name is Manoj Agarwal with the Royal
Bank of Scotland.
The question that's been asked is can India
be a global superpower?
My answer to that is India is already a global
superpower.
We are a nuclear superpower, and that program
has been cemented with
other superpowers like the United States and
is going ahead.
We are an economic superpower.
We are talking about [INAUDIBLE] which are
potentially in excess of
China in the foreseeable future.
We talking about a human capital race, which
India is currently
leading.
I think it is the largest democracy in the
world today.
So there are, of course, a few aspects in
terms of infrastructure, in
terms of health care, in terms of education
that we need to sort out.
But I'm absolutely confident that if you were
to sort of be this
question in ten years' time it would be absolutely
nobody who would
actually be even asking this question, really.
Thanks.